[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about let's do it yeah
nice get this okay
so I went to go see my nephews and
nieces and Boyd the children grow so
fast you know it's crazy you remember
when people used to say that [ __ ] to you
like you're growing up so [ __ ] fast
that's happening to me so my nephew he's
five right and this fall he loves chess
and he [ __ ] made me sweat like like
nothing like you know oh are you good at
chess I mean I played it throughout my
whole life right I understand the game I
wouldn't say I'd play it
what a [ __ ] you all should never win at
chess yeah any table time I didn't he
has a ten year old cousin that was that
dad dad he can't even do it
he can't even win they should be beating
me - Hungry Hungry Hippos not this not
exactly and this fools not even
concentrating he's looking at it and he
goes my time and then he goes over
please and he comes over and then he
just does it and I'm like holy crap and
I'm sitting here thinking like what the
[ __ ] and get this it's one over the
other but they beat Joe and Jess yeah
that's pretty good
no no he didn't beat me I didn't let him
win oh that's good we didn't finish the
game because I gave up too much pressure
and so he was born a five-year-old too
much pressure because okay this is
that's my stress is a component of chess
I like after after dinner after dinner I
was like you want to keep going he goes
now and you're like yeah
[ __ ] oh thank Christ yeah but no he
taught himself wow that's amazing
teachers I asked him I was like I was
like so did you daddy teach you and he
goes no myself it was like they showed
him at least once no no he said I have
it on my iPad and the iPad basically
he's like actually Joseph I bought
myself from the iPad
actually I can continue this
conversation Mandarin you know I speak
Mandarin joke he says that he'll keep
trying with each piece what he can do
and what do you can't crazy so I was
like you're sitting there with every
single piece trying to see where you can
time that's hella true and when they're
being ignored by their parents they
could pick and pick up [ __ ] like chess
that's when they say that kids learn the
fastest is when they're exploring when
they explore something over and over and
over again and they mastered things yeah
because we all thought that he was just
like he loves to eat and chill and in
because his sister had like a lot of
that she taught herself how to read and
write at 3 years old 2 languages I think
so because it's the jeans and then I
don't know the parents are home a lot
and they're always giving them attention
baby I gotta stay home yeah they planned
this so then she was gonna be a stay at
home and then he he saved up so that he
could go part-time and then be more
involved so that he only works a couple
days out of the week or something like
that and so they every morning they'll
be like going to the beach because they
live pretty close to the beach and then
he just sent me a picture the other day
like yeah we just spent two hours
working out at the beach oh he's a
physical therapist so then he can shut
off work like he goes out he does his
thing and then he sees his clients and
he's done that's when he spends the rest
of his time just chillin it's my dream
and the kids are home-schooled
but they get I was like how do they get
there like social stuff so the thing
with homeschooling is they do have group
stuff and then they do have like PE
like there's there's there's still
classes but you get to pick and choose
like where you want to go and all that
stuff yeah yeah I'm like it's [ __ ]
crazy cuz when I thought of home school
I thought oh yeah but I guess that's not
real home school well unless you're you
know a more Mormon polygamy yeah I was
watching two guys watching this [ __ ]
documentary about this [ __ ] it's so
interesting it's called like wah wah
five five wives one husband or some [ __ ]
on Netflix sister wives yeah all the
sister wives [ __ ] and like they all live
in the side of a mountain basically like
that they blast it into then they alway
built houses into the side of the
mountain and it's [ __ ] crazy cuz cuz
they did such a good job of showing how
sad the women are while they talk about
how happy they are I've never seen a
better contrast it's beautiful it's
incredible yeah so it's always just like
we're really we're about expanding God's
kingdom and I'm very happy
like it's like [ __ ] like that where
you're like oh no behind your eyes it's
all there get out it's not so great for
the guy either cuz I watched a
documentary about the guy that has like
seven wives or whatever may not feel bad
so I chose that I feel bad for him he's
gonna bust seven loads or after work
what what happens is after work he
spends all of that time trying to give
attention to all the kids all the wives
and then so that's yeah nobody talks
about how hard he got it's not like he
chose that it's just though that's their
religion or agent right yes mangamma
kingdom he is the one that chose seven
wives though she could have done three
wives so one of the cats brothers his
brother dies and then his brother he's
Lee as he's like you know on a deathbed
or whatever he's like hey will you marry
my wife pick up an extra like bunch of
them yeah so then he's gonna tell
somebody
your uncle becomes your dad yeah who are
the kids yeah I meant today you imagine
you already got like four pissed-off
wives and now you gotta tell them
that we're bringing in to two more wives
yeah do you get the pink slips to these
wives - that's what I'm saying like a
proper good and proper cult they always
say like they could leave any time but
it's like dude they have their kids
there know it exactly but that's what
that's what good proper culture they say
there's the door yeah will you call
those uh um is it Amish okay cuz all
thinking either Quakers or Amish but
Quakers don't exist no more right I
should I'm not cold
hey let's put it like this they bubble
all glass okay the Amish people have
this thing where when kids turn 17 or 18
they're allowed to go off and enjoy the
the secular world you get the experience
electricity for the first time yeah and
then they can party drink whatever
that's fun and then even yeah boys and
girls dig in and they get to make their
choice like you want to be Amish and
live this style or do you want to leave
what do the but then they get
excommunicated though if they leave they
can't come back Taji it is so it is kind
of a cult in that way Wow and most most
of them even though they like the taste
of the regular world they can't leave or
they don't want to or if they do they
regret it yeah they regret like Elmer
Fudd bud they regret doing it they're
like [ __ ]
follow my family and Brandi's own gave
up so they end up coming back to that
world oh I know churning butter or did
you guys remember we talked about that
one family I think it was like a family
of seven or something like that where
they only lived in the New York
apartment like their whole world oh yeah
oh yeah they got the they lived their
own I think the only watched movies or
whatever I met her in a woman like she
came in and she like found out about it
and then like slowly the kids were like
we want to get out of here so they
locked in there yeah dad lock them in
there who's like prove Anderson
there's crazy people all over the world
man well we all know Peruvians are
perfect it's crazy what you think
Salvador white guys like eyeballing me
yeah
Panamanian there they're gonna be pretty
weird dude so mean that you were just uh
you know what the Black Friday because I
have to go I have to go where did you go
we're at the ball there's a mall in
Escondido about why would you do that to
yourself
no because it's so fun to be around the
people in seola oh you just sit there
with popcorn and just watch I do i
people watch the whole time yeah but but
it's fun but it's fun you're all on
YouTube it is but then you don't have to
experience them that you when you're
parking you're like oh why am i doing
this but then once you're there you're
like oh this is why because you just see
all of it up close but then but then we
always get hooked into something cuz
Nicky loves the Bath & Body Works so you
become Black Friday pee bad dude so we
spent like $200 on candles and they're
all incredible they smell good those are
the best candles so we got this one
called hot toddy or whatever and it
smells it like so our whole place is
probably 1,700 square feet it we lit it
in one place you could smell it the
whole [ __ ] so how come how come we can
get a candle that smells like Christmas
mist or whatever the [ __ ] you know I
mean like what is Christmas mate but
right dude it's like half of the things
I'm like this candy cane and Santa Claus
vo but it's but it smells like it yeah
you know saying where it's like if they
say candy cane Santa Clauses bo it's
gonna smell like both of those things or
if it's like blueberry peach cobbler
you're like oh my god that's a Satan
[ __ ] man you shouldn't light those
candles how come they can't do this with
diet food what the [ __ ] is going on
why can't it's like oh this oh this
[ __ ] little wafer tastes like cheese
chicken or something
yeah IRA fried chicken yeah Willy Wonka
was trying to make that happen
this one's saying killed them all that's
true the government killed him there's
good I think the alternative diet foods
now like protein chips I mean they're
good but they're still diet like they
had that diet Feliz yeah dude they can
make
I drink that well I think there's
something going on dude all of that has
just a weird the Arctic thing the best
halo top not near regular eyes I don't
like halo top yeah there's like maybe
two good ones that I can [ __ ] with but
it's nowhere near the you know no right
to it either no the textures well yeah
there's one that's like syrup and
pancakes and I was like it doesn't taste
like that but it's okay give it the Elan
musk he'll he'll fix it yeah baby yeah
like everything but though they're gonna
kill him off I know he's my he's getting
want good luck industry would not like
that
he's already disrupted the car industry
the oil now the [ __ ] milk and the cow
farmers are gonna go after him too you
know because he was smoking weed on the
Joe Rogan show like all his on what says
which is space SpaceX any mission that
they're doing now they're like going
through crazy they have to like jump
through crazy hoops to make it happen
out because you smoke weed yeah cuz they
make it seem like he's the one
controlling like everything that they're
doing in the back like everyone's stoned
at SpaceX yeah [ __ ] making like the
funny like the manufacturer guys the
guys on the assembly Lambo assembly
lines are [ __ ] smoking weed and
[ __ ] it up yeah they're so dumb like
obviously they're just trying to stop
them that's so good that's so stupid
think about what would happen if you
could make broccoli tastes like fast
food fast food or uber everyone looks
amazing everyone's healthy no one's
dying anymore I don't want that that's
on sandy doesn't make the money that's
what I'm saying
then what who's gonna need pills and all
that [ __ ] that's like cotton candy
grapes how do they do it it's incredible
its life you know a person eats cotton
candy for a whole month and then farts
on it what that's what they do TIFF it's
like cat [ __ ]
coffee it's frowned upon in many
cultures but we love it and also the
grapples what's a ground grape flavored
Apple III uh yeah I was it tastes like
grape it tastes like something other
than Apple plum and tangerine should
they have all kinds of stuff did you buy
any more stuff
[ __ ] yeah dude me and Nikki went to we
went to I love how you went to judge
Black Friday people literally what you
do with Walmart people now you can see
what you sound like yeah we go to
Walmart we were just there yeah that's
what you sound like
but I know I'm buying yeah so are they
do you we went to Michael's and spent
like [ __ ] three hundred dollars on
whatever
I love Michaels but I am NOT one
sorrowful I don't even know I'm like we
bought some Garland's I guess on my
house or expensive what the [ __ ] cigar
like 30 bucks each just to decorate the
house yeah decorate that looks good now
the house looks sick Merry Christmas
thing that middle thing was probably
best because Michaels is or it is top
notch stuff it is it small you should
have just went to Walmart Target stop
notch in my opinion we spent like three
hundred dollars at Target we bought a
bunch of Christmas lights and [ __ ] I
put up his first Christmas lights ever
his whole life you mean on the house or
in the house outside of the house
decorated I'm over you'll see someone it
took him like four hours and it's like
that's the first time I ever did such a
good job I have to figure out how to do
it to a home that only has stucco like
nobody I know you're so smart the way
you did it oh good when he all of a
sudden each other Christmas party who's
having the Christmas pen we can have one
yeah destroy yeah we realize that like
we actually have a good amount of space
we just got a rearrange every weekend I
get too much maybe this night we don't
give a [ __ ] about of his play space
upstairs yeah he does my sister's place
is [ __ ] nuts
more than ours Oh nights like nicer no
it's [ __ ] nuts like like hoarder
mentality like kids [ __ ] everywhere in
every corner of every kisses you got one
now well now she has two she's a working
professional though but dude it's just
nuts man like my brother-in-law's like I
can't even walk in the place like cuz
it's just nuts it's the kids loved it's
got a lot of toys if Keith has too many
toys it makes no sense nuts
it's nots dude I wanted to get a house
just so I could put up Christmas
decorations and I wanted a train that
wraps around the house
oh that is so cool one inside like the
small model one that goes all over but
then the big one saw the neighbor kids
could come over and ride baby
yep that's what I always wanted I just
became Michael Jackson supervised to
make sure there's no no you geez gonna
give him hot milk
I'm not Bart and it's very charming why
it's not part you just [ __ ] kitty
lifting there you on a bus parkour
because that's a joke that's the first
time I'll just make another apology
video you know do we apologize for what
Joe just said yeah okay I'm sorry that
Joe said that pedal bar but there was no
train okay was no train that's good you
know you know those neighborhoods where
they have like like that family that
always does [ __ ] [ __ ]
like I want to do that I would love that
have like all the like Tigers friends
come over and I'll play like I want to
bring back the haunted house for
Halloween I want to like I don't know
there's no sense of community or maybe
I'm just not that age y'all just live in
the same [ __ ] coldest that that's
what we're gonna do know what someone
sent me an article of a bunch of friends
that did you see that yeah I didn't see
when they built like a whole entire like
track house hold a sack thing and then
it's all friends that grew up to four
houses one of them is for all of them to
live there I mean to whenever they want
to like have dinner together whatever
they need in that house yeah
so they have their eat their own houses
what a big house holy [ __ ] they're bald
then then they just have that one house
where they can all meet like pulled in
their money for that one house I think
so we can do it's like a model home we
could do two just gotta move all of the
Laverne or some [ __ ] oh I mean I'm
doubtful yeah the place is the place is
far away we'll buy a whole block don't
have agus jets girl
oh my friends are killing in Vegas they
love it well your friends also are doing
really well that's true we're not doing
that way that's true that's really
companies go to Vegas I like Vegas as
uh-oh
Asus I do like the desert but not the
Nevada desert
I like the New Mexico or Mariana it's
all not desert but I feel like Vegas is
so [ __ ] dope and airconditioning
shared the hotels are everything is
though think about it I don't know man
bye there you have to have a sea bass
you guys don't wanna make it happen
and we're already looking for a house
and you guys already know or the ones
that you guys know I've never going to
another part we can't do [ __ ] cos
Bitcoin went down don't you understand
your monster we have to wait for Bitcoin
to go me and Steve took a different
route we went big baby we all know what
I had a house - yeah we got away we just
got away hey hey watch it in 40 years
alright in 40 years hey you know what
Ohio is accepting Bitcoin for their tax
payment exactly but I wouldn't even want
to use it right now no I would be the
Bitcoin goes up whatever house we buy I
could pay that [ __ ] off hell one payment
what you mean I my money's in there -
what the [ __ ] did you know that Bitcoin
right now does more payments than PayPal
really yes it does
so exactly we're gonna be fine drug
dealers buying [ __ ] it's not drug
dealers that many drug dealers I know
dude drug dealers use cash yeah when you
go to those warehouses it's all [ __ ]
cab dealers just kill people they don't
have to use any money
oh [ __ ] you're talking about the cartel
drug dealers use venmo like hey what's
your mm okay cool the QR code yeah oh
hey I'm bad guy three three it's all I
see yeah
like you're thinking of El Chapo we're
thinking about the white guy with
dreadlocks that lives in Santa Cruz
okay so our man at my gym manager just
told me this but there's someone selling
drugs right like using barbells address
to have the people meet him there so
we've been getting a lot of like
crackheads and [ __ ] coming in asking for
a mr. Miyagi that's his truck mr. Miyagi
yes hi so it's Frankie Miyagi that's the
name that he uses so you think this
Filipino cat or whatever and all these
crackheads come inside the gym and I'm
like hey is Frankie or mr. Miyagi here
you need a higher security for the
outside yeah so we're like what the [ __ ]
is going on
and then they're like yeah this is six
for six Gibbons right that's the gym
address um and then he's like they're
like yeah but no one by that name is
Frank you me someone saw him but then
yeah I think that's I think they called
the cops or something that's the last
place I would do that it cuz if you
needed to do something it's like you're
gonna you run into somebody yoke people
hey you do this [ __ ] here
oh no weird selling crack next door yeah
ladies that are at the sewing place next
day they're not there anymore oh it's
empty now do it at the Fry's Electronics
cuz the employees there don't pay
attention to anything yeah hate you and
they have really big car parking lots
yeah exactly
it's huge car Lots I did parking lots
and car Lots together yeah you could you
could do a deal drug deal in the store
you can do drug deals there because the
if you even ask me like hey can I get
some help doing yeah okay hold on a
second and then they just go [ __ ] off
[Music]